[موسيقى]
مع زيادة عدد السيارات على الطرق،
التحول بعيدًا عن
المركبات التي تعمل بالوقود التقليدي تكتسب
زخمًا أكثر من 26 مليون سيارة كهربائية
كانت على الطريق في عام 2022 وفقًا
لوكالة الطاقة الدولية، بزيادة قدرها 60٪
عن عام
2021 وهذا العام العدد هو
من المتوقع أن تكون
أعلى من ذلك، في حين ظهرت السيارات التي تعمل بالبطاريات
كحل واعد لتقليل
انبعاثات الكربون، حيث أن اعتمادها على
الليثيوم يثير
مخاوف التعدين لمعالجة هذه السيارات، حيث تم
تصميمها لتعمل على أحد
العناصر الأكثر وفرة على الأرض، الهيدروجين الذي
تحدثنا إليه مع الإدارة  مدير إحدى
العلامات التجارية للسيارات الفاخرة المعترف بها عالميًا
هنا في دبي والذي قدم لنا
نظرة حصرية على بعض الطرازات المثيرة التي
نقفها الآن هنا في مركز تدريب BMW
حيث نقوم بتدريب جميع
موظفينا الذين يواجهون عملائنا في
التدريبات الفنية وغير الفنية.  أنا
مهتم بشكل خاص بهذا
الجمال هنا، هذا هو الهيدروجين 5، نعم إنه كذلك
ولكن الجزء الأكثر إثارة للاهتمام
هو ما يوجد أسفل غطاء المحرك وهو عبارة عن
مركبة تعمل بالهيدروجين، لذا فإن الطريقة التي
تشحنها بها هي في الأساس تزويدها بالوقود
وتزويدها بالهيدروجين  يستغرق الأمر من دقيقتين
إلى ثلاث دقائق لتزويد السيارة بالوقود، والجمال
هو أن الماء فقط يخرج من
أنبوب العادم، ولا يوجد أي انبعاثات صفر صفر حسنًا، لم
يتبق سوى شيء واحد للقيام به وهو
أنه عليك أن تأخذني في جولة بالسيارة بنسبة 100٪
لدينا  سيارة تنتظر بالخارج،
فلنفعل
ذلك حاليًا، يبلغ عدد
السيارات التي تعمل بالهيدروجين على الطريق
72000، ويتوقع خبراء الصناعة أنه بحلول
عام 2050، يمكن أن يرتفع الأسطول العالمي من سيارات الهيدروجين
إلى 400 مليون، لكن
تكلفة الإنتاج المرتفعة قد تشكل
عائقًا، لذلك في الوقت الحالي  التكاليف
مرتفعة، هذا طيار اختباري أو مركبة
لدينا، ولكن مع الاعتماد الشامل،
من الواضح أن وفورات الحجم ستنخفض،
ما هي السرعة التي تعتقد أن ذلك يمكن أن
يحدث بها، ما هو الجدول الزمني قبل أن نرى
الاعتماد الشامل، ما نعرضه هنا هو
القدرات  من الهيدروجين الذي يتم
نشره على السيارة والذي يمكننا أنا وأنت
قيادته، ما نراه هو أنه مع
نشر البنية التحتية
نتوقع أنه بحلول نهاية هذا العقد
سنكون مستعدين لامتلاك
مركبات هيدروجينية في الإنتاج الجاد لذلك
دعونا نتحدث عنها  هل ترى من الناحية الواقعية
والعملية نقطة
لن نحتاج فيها إلى الوقود الأحفوري لتشغيل
مركباتنا، وكم من الوقت
سيستغرق ذلك، هل تعتقد أن الهيدروجين سيكون موجودًا
إذا نظرت إلى القطاع نفسه، لديك
شاحنات، لديك سفن، لديك طائرات، وإذا نظرت إلى القطاع نفسه، لديك شاحنات، لديك سفن، لديك
طائرات، وإذا  تريد أن تكون على الطريق
نحو الحياد الكربوني، وتحتاج
أيضًا إلى إيجاد طريقة لجعلها خضراء وعادةً
ما يكون الهيدروجين هو الوسيلة لتحقيق
ذلك